lance lynn going to the hill for his
11th start he's looking for his eighth
win his era
is easy as one two three 63 strikeouts
and 58 and two-thirds with only 17
walks left-handed right-handed really
doesn't matter and he throws a lot of
fastballs
the cutter the four-seamer and the
sinker all fastball
filthy cutter simeon disposed of one
gone
3-1 and a fastball grounded just to the
left of the third baseman of moncada and
it'll bounce into
left field a one ounce single for buchet
in the top of the first so beshette is
aboard with one out here's guerrero
inching off the base he doesn't run and
that's called strike three
wow borderline pitch and lance will take
his second strikeout
the stretch and the one-two swinging a
miss
strike three but lynn with three
strikeouts in the first
elect manoa a king-sized right-hander
this is third start the era
386. he's a unique personality and last
time out he gave up three home runs to
miami 12 strikeouts and nine in the
third the stuff is pretty good the five
walks
isn't good little tapper
manoa makes the call and loads up a dart
that's dropped by guerrero and i don't
blame him
that was a laser from manoa yeah manoa
figured as long as he was that close he
might as well throw it harder than he's
pitching
man on one out and the batter is johan
monkatta
the 1-1 bounce into left the base hit
rounding third heading home is lamb the
throw
there gets away from the catcher mcguire
the white sox lead one to nothing took
seven innings for a run yesterday
three batters today and now abreu is
down
it was helping the runner coming home
with
which direction to come into the plate
eric bakkus threw the bat
back and he threw it right into abreu's
knee
right into his shin oh my gosh
jose is going to hit now yeah it's just
a little bet that nailed him in the knee
no big deal jose to third
jumping grab by panic 2-2
swing and a miss elevating the fastball
manoa
strikes out grondon
randall grichik with a swing and a fly
ball left field it's deep
and it is gone gretchik with his 13th
home run
on the season and the blue jays have
tied it at one
the kick and the payoff falls strike
three
fastball at the knees pinpoint thread
the needle lands two down
[Applause]
teles goes golfing into right center
field it is garcia to glove it
with two down third inning 1-1 3-2
got one over the plate pops it down the
right field line
eaton can't get there and it drops in
fair
and bushettes got himself a bloop single
well he earned that
3-1 and a fastball line to second and
caught by madrigal
well if laddie hit it hard but a right
at the second baseman no runs a base hit
and a man left to the bottom of the
third in a one-one
time right-hand batter in the 6-6 manoa
deals and there's a blast out into deep
right center
it's going to bang off the wall anderson
on his way to second the throw there by
grizzick is late it's a double
the 1-1 is popped up back of third panic
will give way to beshette who will make
the catch
in fair territory manoa gets monkatta
and the white sox strand to run over
third it's still
time two down for joe panic who popped
up in foul territory to the third
baseman his first time up
swings at the first pitch and he pulls
it into right field for a base hit
and the blue jays with a two out base
runner in the fourth inning in this one
one tie
another 2-2 cutting to miss strike three
first strikeout for lynn since he fanned
guriel back in the second
so runner at second two down and andrew
vaughan is the battery grounded out to
third his first time up
swinging a base hit into left field
over to get it but a rounding third
heading home grondell the throw
got him at the plate grandal
right away motions to the dugout to have
a look
maybe saying that maguire never
actually got the tag down on him
and i think grandau beats it with that
good slide and spikes home plate
with his left leg and the call will
stand
it will be an out at the plate eighth
outfield assist
of the season for goriel and this game
is still tied
at one two and two
struck him out one gone six strikeouts
for lynn
he won't strike three and lance with a
flourish with the hand in the ear
like he just knocked down at three from
28 feet
the batter nick madrigal who grounded
out to short his first time on 1-1 tie
in the bottom of the fifth
there goes garcia that ball hit deep to
left center it's going to roll for a
while garcia around thirds going to
score
that's a double for nick madrigal
and the sox lead 2-1
2-1 white sox bottom five and a swing
and a miss
95 mile an hour fastball for a big
second out with a runner still stuck at
third
and the 2-2 swing and a ball popped up
back of third panic gives way to bechet
who makes the catch
and manoa minimize the damage one run
for the white sox they lead the blue
jays two to one at the end of five
three infielders to the left of second
base
the pitch got him looking on a cutter
guerrero having a little chat with eric
bakkus
eight strikeouts for lance lynn he did
and he gunned him down oh lancelin is
amped
he's feeling it he has fanned through
six
lance lynn still working as we get into
the seventh inning
1-0 pitch popped up on the infield
near the mound it'll be guess who jose
abreu
to make the catch guriel
on the ground right side a one hopper
handled by
madrigal he throws to first that'll do
it lin's through
seven two outs nobody on bottom seven
the pitch to madrigal tapped on the
ground softly toward third bare-handed
pick
panic throw to first he got him on a
very close play the white sox do not
have a challenge here and madrigal
is down i don't think he hit the back
that's why
yep yep that's a good call over at first
by dan bellino
and boy i'm hoping this is not an
achilles but
this is just a very bad sign
the bases are loaded for vladimir
guerrero jr
and toronto in the eighth here it comes
down and in bowl four to force in a run
and tie the game as
adams crosses the plate 3-0 on the way
and he
swung at it and hit a ground ball to
second
and then an errant throw as the blue
jays catch
another huge break and two runs are
going to score on the play
rowdy teles is the batter especially
second one down
and tolas with a liner in the right for
a base head
espinal is getting away heading home and
will
score it is 5-2 blue jays
simeon with a ground ball to short
anderson to second one
and the throw off the glove of abreu and
another run will come into score
6-2 blue jays sox are down to their
final out tonight
0-2 pitch ground ball to short
backhanded by beshette throw is in time
and the blue jays will win it
a weird game in chicago but they get it
done